Hi everyone. Thanks for joining
this authors at this lunch time. Uh,
I'm Yasmin Green. I, uh,
run research and development
for a group called Jigsaw,
which is alphabet's technology incubator.
They can't geopolitics.
And I am delighted to welcome
Gwen de sacs to talk to us today.
Um, we're related, um,
where we've got to figure out like
the exact way to, to describe it,
but Wendy's the sister of my,
uh, husband's cousin's wife, um,
there should be a short term,
short, short hand for that. Um,
so if you guys are anything like me,
you feel some anxiety when you think
about the evolving nature of work and a
automation and globalization seem
like they're trends that, uh,
making more bleak,
the prospects of us all being
gainfully employed in the future. Um,
and job security seems like
a kind of romantic notion,
um, from a past era. Um,
and yet we still want,
you know,
Yan Fridge for work that's a noshing
and stimulating and flexible.
And that brings us joy as
well as pays the bills. Um,
and, uh, sometimes we fantasize
about charting a new path, uh,
but we're not even sure where we'd
start. Yeah. When it comes to that.
So when we love the advice of somebody
who has experience with every possible
permutation of work life,
family,
and has reinvented themselves and captured
their insights in a book that will
help empower us and help us or thrive.
And that is Wendy Sachs.
That's the brilliance of Wendy.
And Wendy has a very diverse
and accomplished career, um,
as a Emmy award winning producer
of a TV news on date night and BBC,
CNN, Fox and NBC, um,
is a critically acclaimed
author and journalist and has a,
um,
an eclectic career and politics in PR,
including holding the title of not
going to get this right. No, wait,
she can credit me Capitol Hill,
chief
press secretary,
Capitol Hill for a secretary.
I'm editor in chief and also,
which I didn't get the full
one one from her about,
but also a representative of
Barney the purple dinosaur.
So, um, anyway, without further ado, um,
it's a great joy to welcome Wendy
to share her insights with us today.
Yep.
Thanks so much.
Thank you for that warm introduction.
I'm,
I'm honored to be related to Yaz
even by some sort of cousin marriage.
I'm
talking about fearless.
I think that I don't know anyone who has
more fearless and Badass and this woman
who's doing incredible
work here at Google. Um,
so I say that I've pivoted so much in
my career that I'm practically a wedding
and you know, not all of my pivots
have been intentional. I've been fired,
I've lost my job a couple
of times and you know,
because everything today has
an origin story, you know,
every brand, everything. Um,
my origin story of fearless
and free begins when I lost
my job in August of 2014
and um, I was working at a
advertising agency and you know,
sort of in mini tragedy to
lose your job and advertising.
It happens all the time. Um, and they,
they gave me some notice and I knew I
was going to be let go because I couldn't
afford me anymore apparently.
And I started interviewing
all around New York City.
I started going to all of these, what I
would call the bright and shiny startups.
I'm sure you work with many
of them here in New York.
And I was going around looking for
a job. My industry, media, you know,
had been completely disrupted by digital.
And I started really panicking because
at this point I'm over 40 and I'm in an
industry that is, you know, overrun by
people now about 20 years younger than me.
And I thought if I don't get a job soon,
I'm not going to be relevant.
And of course, as we all
know, relevance is everything.
So I was interviewing at one shop and I
went in and of course it is, you know,
a bearded millennial and that Flan all
like the total cliche sitting across from
me. And I take out, start
taking out my resume,
which is sort of lengthy at this,
at this point in my bio.
And I handed him right away. I knew
that there was trouble. Um, he said,
we don't take paper resumes around here,
we only want digital copies.
And I was like, oh, a feeling
embarrassed and shamed.
And that clearly I was way too
old for this company. I shoved my,
my paper back in my bag and he opens up
his Mac book and he's looking over my
resume and he sees that I
had worked on Capitol Hill.
I was a press secretary Oh,
while ago.
But I still kept it on my resume because
it was a position that I always felt
very proud of.
You know,
up until this point had given me
some gravitas and some credibility.
And like a lot I like to say is that
Capitol Hill was the Google of the gen x
generation. It opened doors for us and
open big careers for many people. We all,
you know, many people I know started
there, went onto to big, big careers.
But here, you know that the man looking
at me sort of scoffed and said, you know,
around here we have good
relationships with the media.
I wouldn't want you hanging up on any
reporters or anything. And I, you know,
completely startled by this. I
said, you know, jokingly, well,
I'm not a character in
veep or the house of cards.
I wasn't screaming at reporters,
I was begging them to cover
my member of Congress.
He was a freshman member from
accredited district in south Florida.
He didn't even laugh at any
of this. So after I, you know,
started walking through the office,
holding onto my paper resume and
grabbing my coconut water and Kale chips.
As I walked out,
I'm feeling sort of depressed.
I was walking down Fifth Avenue
and I thought to myself, you know,
something's got to change.
Obviously I have, you know,
I've done what I think has been, you
know, very interesting jobs in my career.
I'm clearly qualified for these positions.
What am I doing wrong?
And I had this sort of epiphany and I
started looking towards silicon valley.
I was sort of always,
you know,
obsessed with the tech world
the way that so many of us are.
And because that toll startup spirit
and tech world and Silicon Valley's
basically directing everything
we do today, as you know,
better than anyone from how we shop to
how we get our news and our attainment,
how we target isis.
You know,
everything we do is coming
from the startup space,
silicon valley, the tech world.
So one of the,
one of the themes and one of the sort of
characteristics that sort of struck me
at this time,
and it was because I had seen this New
York magazine article about that whole
failure, failure fetish coming out of
Silicon Valley. And I thought, well,
I understand failure. I've
failed a few times. Um,
but what is it about that whole failure
idea, that embracing of failure,
that's so, you know,
part of the DNA of the,
of the tech world and why is it a badge
of honor for these boys and the hoodies
who launched companies that blow up,
they're not going in climbing into
a hole and disappearing. No, I mean,
from what I'm reading,
they're getting rehired or they're
just pivoting on their business, right?
That the venture capitalists are investing
in the people and the talent behind
the business, not necessarily the business
idea. And of course there's a, you know,
dozens of examples to point to. So I
just love that idea. And I thought,
what if women did that
in their own careers?
What have women sort of own that concept
that we don't need to feel shamed if we
lose a job?
And so many people do today,
what if we really sort of invested in
ourselves and leaned into our own skills
and realize we just need to pivot.
We need to iterate.
And what if we were okay
with that idea of failure?
So as I started sort of digging
into this concept of a failure,
of course a cousin happy cousin to
failure is success and it Albert Einstein,
so many people have these great quotes
around failure. He says, you know,
failure is the pathway to
success. Something like
that. I'm paraphrasing that.
But you know, that's that idea. So I
started looking at confidence, right?
So confidence is the foundation to,
to building anything,
to taking risks. And it's all about
the risk taking. And of course,
I'm sure you're all familiar with all
of the studies that show, you know,
men are more willing to
take risks and women,
we know men start more companies more.
It's startups in women.
They certainly get the financing,
the venture capital backing that women
don't get, you know. So why is that? Um,
so as I started looking into some
of the research around confidence,
I was looking at Claire
Shipman and Katty Kay,
I don't know if anyone here is familiar
with their book, the Confidence Code,
which sort of became my Bible as I was
doing my own research on confidence and
they found that there's this genetic
connection with confidence that there's
actually,
you know,
there's a genetic component sort of like
you know who gets blue eyes or curly
hair and they did their own DNA testing
and they found very disappointing lay
that they,
neither one of them carry that genetic
trade to actually create confidence.
And of course this was incredibly
disheartening to them because you want to
think that you are, you know,
genetically enabled to be confident.
But what they also found,
which of course is very empowering,
is that we can build confidence.
Confidence is a muscle like resilience
is a muscle that Sheryl Sandberg of
course is recently talking about.
Confidence is also a muscle.
And the fastest way to become
confident is to take risks.
And women just chat generally
are more risk averse in,
we're taught this at an early age,
we don't like to fail,
we don't like to get things wrong.
We don't like to take as many
chances in hysterics really early on.
So the more studies that I was uncovering
and looking at the writings of Carol
Dweck, who's a well known professor
and she wrote a book called Mindset,
she writes about that this starts at a
very early age with that whole idea of a
growth mindset versus fixed mindset.
The idea that we sort of only know what
we know is that fixed mindset that you
know, you, you are good at
math and that is what you know,
but you would not be good at perhaps art.
Um,
verse.
That whole idea of a growth mindset that
you can develop your skills and you can
turn into, you can sort of evolve
and you can iterate as you go. Well,
this is really important,
not just in the parenting space
as it became recently adopted,
because there's that whole concept
that we're not supposed to tell her our
daughters at.
They're good at math because maybe
in fifth grade they're good at math,
but by ninth grade when math gets
hard and they're not doing so well,
they now take it personally and think,
I guess I'm just not so good at math.
We're supposed to praise the journey.
So,
but this is also very true to ourselves.
If we can't accept the idea that we can
continue to evolve and grow while we're
going to get stuck. So these
things were very interesting to me.
This whole risk taking versus growth
mindset versus fixed mindset and how we
think about ourselves and how you know,
our ability and our willingness
to really take risks.
But along with this whole confidence and
internal internalization of how we're
feeling, it's also about
how we present to the world.
And so as I was writing this book,
the book is not a memoir,
but it very much a personal journey for
me as I was exploring my own sort of,
you know, what was happening out
there in the workforce and how,
what I needed to change.
And it was also the election.
And so during the election of course
we saw how women are perceived.
Of course the person carrying the mantle
for all of us was Hillary Clinton.
And we saw that the way that she was
perceived to, you know, to the voters,
to the population, to the media was that
she came across as either too shrill,
too on earth and authentic.
She wasn't warm enough.
She was judged to a different
standard. And there is this, you know,
famous Jimmy Kimmel sketch that,
I don't know if any of you saw,
but I write about in the book
and in this one sketch he sorted,
this is like what they called
the mansplaning sketch. And she,
so Hillary's you standing behind a podium
and she's pretending that she's giving
her stump speech and she starts out,
you know, a little bit loud. And He, Oh,
you know, keep it down. Keep
it down. The voice, the voice,
it's a little too shrill,
a little too loud. She drops it
down. You got to raise your voice.
You're sounding like a mouse up there.
And then she begins again and he's like,
you don't look for it. You got to
smile more. You've got to smile.
So she starts smiling. You look like a
Lakers, girls, what's with the smile?
You know, whatever she did and it went
on and on. And then he's like, you know,
I can't put my finger on it.
I'm not sure. What is it?
What is it about you that's just
not right? I know you're not a man.
You're not a man. And that of course
was, you know, the ultimate, you know,
poking fun at exactly what was happening
and exactly how she was being perceived.
Um, and, and that of
course is the double bind.
And I'm sure is everyone here
familiar with that double bind?
The women in leadership at the double
bind is the ultimate conundrum for women
and leadership.
And that is that when women present
with more masculine characteristics that
they are direct, are there, have a
loud voice or they come off, you know,
very strong, they're not well
liked. There seem, you know,
people see them as abrasive or
they're bitches, they're not well,
they're not well liked.
But when women present with their
more feminine qualities that they are
nurturing and it seemed to be warm,
engaging,
maybe their voice isn't so loud,
they're not thought to be strong leaders.
So that's the conundrum,
right? That is the double bind.
And then of course we saw that
play out during the campaign.
Not to say that Hillary Clinton didn't
have, you know, other issues going on,
but that was a big part of
it. So all of this, you know,
is happening as I'm writing the book, the
campaign, I'm watching what's happening.
And by the way, you know, just to
compare and contrast, when you saw it,
you knew this was not just a Democrat,
republican thing. You see Bernie Sanders,
who's, you know, pounding the podium and
finger thrusting and he's messy and he's,
you know, disheveled and he's loud
and he's angry. And people love that.
Right? People love that about Bernie.
There was no, you're too loud.
You're too obnoxious. Your hair's
a mess. Fix your tie, you know,
stop with the finger. No,
that was manly. It was alpha.
It was legitimate. It was authentic,
and people loved it. Women loved it.
So that's really, really, that
was very fascinating to me.
And I think at some level,
I also had this sort of personal
association with all of this.
Not that I'm anywhere near a Hillary
Clinton's level, um, or will be,
but I had been viewed in the workforce
at one particular job as being too
abrasive.
I was told this in one of my job reviews
that I came across as a little bit too
abrasive to tough.
Um,
what I thought was being direct other
people viewed and perceived as being the
word that's commonly associated
with women is abrasive.
And I was horrified. I was. So I felt so,
um, I don't want to say ashamed,
but I felt so hurt actually.
I mean,
I,
I didn't want people not to like me
because everyone wants to be liked.
And by the way, likability and the
workforce goes a really long way. Um,
so I didn't know what
to do about all of this.
And so at the same time that this was
all happening and I was feeling very sad
about, you know, not being liked. Um,
I wound up actually getting a new job and
I went to the advertising agency I had
mentioned before and I started saying,
sorry a lot.
I was just dropping in. Sorry. Sorry.
Sorry. Where do I hang this report?
Sorry. Opening the door. You know,
when I go into a room, sorry.
And I was adopting this, sorry, because
there was another colleague of mine who,
granted she was like blond in
puttied and dimpled and very sweet.
She would always say sorry.
And no one ever thought that she was a
bitch or that she was too direct or that
she came across as abrasive.
So I thought I'm going to use this whole
sorry thing and it worked like a charm.
I'm telling you,
I was with the like toughest
creative guys who are, you know,
feeling all bold and, and
all, all that going on.
But no one thought I was being
too direct because I wasn't,
I had dialed it back.
And so interestingly at this time
at the agency where I was working,
there was a Pantene commercial that came
out and I don't know if you remember,
it was a few years ago and it got a lot
of recognition and it was a campaign
where they were showing it was for
Pantene and there were showing all these
different circumstances
of women apologizing.
So in one scene you see a woman on
a subway and a man sits next hurt,
his legs are spread open and she's
doing this and she says, sorry.
And in another scene
you see a kitchen and,
and the woman is handing over a child,
which looks like it's either to
her husband or partner or whoever.
As she handed the baby over, she
says, sorry, another instance,
a woman in an office is opening up a door.
There's men sitting at the
table and she says, sorry.
And so it was a whole slew of Saris and
basically they were making fun of the
fact that women are
apologizing all the time.
So now I'm feeling sorry for saying sorry.
And I quickly dropped my sorry.
And it was at the ad agency where I was
working at that they actually produce
the ad. So it was just like total
sort of awakening of what's going on.
Um, and uh, during this time also,
I'm sure you also heard of all of the
other shrinker words that people talk
about the justice and
the actually's and the,
am I making sense and all the language
that really diminishes our power.
And Are you,
does anyone know Tammy Reese in this room?
So Tammy Reese actually created a g
plugin that was going to be like these
spellcheck four, sorry. And
it got a lot of attention.
I see some heads saying yes,
it got a lot of attention. And,
and I interviewed her for the book and
she talks about the fact that it wasn't
supposed to change the way
that we communicate entirely.
Like saying you know like shame
on you for saying just, you know,
because we think that sort of breezy
sometimes you want to say just in a
sentence,
but her,
her feeling was she wanted to make women
aware of the language that they were
using and how we are presenting to
the world because it is so incredibly
important to how we present.
And so some of the suggestions that
when I started asking some experts like,
okay,
we use these Justin,
the actually is because we don't want
to be seen as abrasive and to direct.
So we try to come across as a little,
a little softer,
but the suggestions are open in
your email, warm and in your email,
warm in the middle scrubbing.
He just actually is in my making sense.
And that's the smartest approach you do.
And you can do that in person too.
When you walk into a meeting,
you can start with some small talk about
the weather or whatever and but then be
direct, smile and warm, you're done like,
but there are no apologizing. And so
I thought that was really also very,
very interesting.
What is it that women are doing that is
in an advertently effecting our power,
diminishing our strength to the world.
So another theme that I also looked at,
um, when again looking towards Silicon
Valley for all of my answers, um,
I looked at that concept
of engineering serendipity.
Do you all know what that is?
I feel like this is a group that
engineering serendipity. So,
so many of us think of serendipity
as a happy accident, right?
She's good fortune somehow like
great things just happened.
But actually there is
strategy behind serendipity.
We can make that magic happen.
And a few years ago at south by southwest,
it being a peak,
it actually became sort of
a theme of the conference.
There was a bunch of sessions of,
with creative agencies and tech companies
all talking about this concept of
engineering serendipity.
We can create these amazing collisions
of creativity. And innovation. Um,
which to me was incredibly
eye opening. Like, oh,
we can actually make these
things happen for us. Um,
so the one man in my book is a
guy named Mike and he's the only,
he's the only dude in the book.
And um,
I call him the king of serendipity because
while we have worked together several
times,
so I've benefited from his own kingdom
of serendipity because he's hired me a
few times.
He was always able to sort of maneuver
between a whole bunch of different things.
He was working for Larry Ellison and
running some sort of startup company.
He also was writing screenplays. He's
also producing digital series. He,
he was able, and he started
out as a TV news journalist.
So he somehow was able to, you
know, zig zag between industries,
make money, have three children and
to me like sort of live the dream.
And I would look to him thinking,
how is he doing that? Well,
part of it I realized is that he is a guy.
So when he would invite me to go to, you
know, networking events, he'd say, Hey,
you should come out for drinks. You know,
I'm meeting with this, you know, you know,
movie producer,
he's in from La and we're talking
about this script that I just wrote.
I would say, you know, I got to catch
the train. I got to get home. And,
but somehow he was able to
keep building his network,
keep expanding his boundaries,
and keep creating this magic for himself.
So when I was looking into this whole
concept of Engineering Serendipity,
I interviewed Mike and I said,
what is it? How did you do this?
He actually had a formula for serendipity.
I couldn't believe it.
He has a mathematical equation that I'm
not going to be able to remember right
now. It's in my book, but it's
about visibility, you know,
sort of dividing by,
you know,
what you've done in the past
and where you're located in.
And it was like a whole formula to
creating this perfect magic for himself.
But what he was doing was something
that's actually been studied for many,
many years.
And it's about this idea that
you're opening boundaries
and as you are expanding
your networks, you're creating
opportunities for yourself,
but you're also being seen.
You're also being visible in,
you're putting in the work, so it's
not just magically appearing for you.
You've actually done your homework,
you've started a project,
you've done some research, you've,
you've, you know, created your side Gig.
So you're doing something on the side.
So now you're actually sort of
getting there. You're, you're making,
you're taking the steps to get there and
now you're putting yourself in a place,
whether it's a networking event or a
conference or some sort of meetup where
you're meeting with the right people.
And then the key to all of it is that
you're seizing on the opportunity that
you're ready for it.
You,
you now have your eyes wide open and you
can see the opportunity and you seize
the moment. You don't,
you're not held back by fear.
You're not held back by
feeling not confident. Um,
so I thought that was really,
really fascinating. And by the way,
as I was exploring serendipity,
I saw that it happens here at Google.
But you all must know about,
I mean this whole innovation
time off the 20% I don't know,
does anyone actually do
that? They take, okay,
that is brilliant and revolutionary and
that's another time where your company
is saying to you, go explore,
go innovate, go be creative,
go take,
have the head space to go
work on something because
we know that when you have
the time and this sort
of mental space to do it,
great things are gonna happen.
And that is really,
really similar to this whole notion of
serendipity and what has held a lot of
women back. And I was actually
interviewing a guy who's
writing an entire book on
Serendipity,
is he said that women don't
generally have the time to noodle.
We don't have the time to be creative.
When we're working a full time job and
we have a family and you're rushing to
get home, pick up your child
from daycare or make a train,
you just don't have that time built in.
Whereas men just sort of
either create the time,
aren't racing to get to the train or
relieve the babysitter from daycare or
their nanny this in the same
way and they have more time.
So I do think that there's
definitely sort of a gender divide,
a bit of a gender gap in this area because
we tend to not have the time or not
take it upon ourselves to
be able to engineer this,
this moment for ourselves.
A serendipity. Um,
the other issue that of
course I kept exploring,
which is part and parcel to everything in,
in the tech world today is networking,
right? So it's all about networking.
Everything we do today is networking.
You know, that does, that is, that is the
sort of foundation of how we connect. Um,
and it's all about the networks.
But one of the things that women
haven't really had until very recently,
our really strong female networks.
And I will tell you,
and I'm older than maybe a lot of
you are sitting here in the room,
but when I was coming up through
the ranks and I worked in media, um,
I had a lot of female bosses,
but I never felt as if I didn't feel
like it was an all out cat fight where we
were like crawling over each other,
trying to like get to the top.
But I didn't feel like any of my bosses
or any of the women who I worked with,
they were trying to lift me with them.
I didn't feel like they were raising me.
I do feel like there was a smaller
piece of the pie at the top.
They wanted to hold onto it,
so they didn't sort of pull
me along in the process.
What I have really seen a huge change
in the past few years or the amount of
female networks out there in all
different industries. Of course,
you probably know about
the tech industry is,
and there's so many here in New York and
there's so many in different, you know,
from Nashville to Austin to San Francisco.
What I'm talking about a whole
bunch of different industries.
I have a friend who was actually,
she's an interior designer.
She was out and think Sun Valley a few
weekends ago with her female network of
designers.
And of course they're using technology.
They're using the whatsapp chats and all
of the in Facebook and different groups
to connect and to support each other.
This just didn't exist in the same way.
So I was, as I was really sort of
digging into female networks. Um,
of course I found the one that maybe some
of you know about tech lady Mafia Tech
Lady Mafia. So Amina sow, create
a tech lady mafia with a friend.
And the whole idea around, around
this network, not just, you know,
let's connect and support each other.
But they actually have done
something really, really,
I think unique and really empowering
for women and that they've codified this
whole concept of asking
for something and offering.
So when you show up to a meetup for,
for Tech Lady Mafia,
it's that you might need something from
someone and you're also willing to give.
Because here's the thing we do.
Women do not like to ask for help.
We don't like to say, Hey, can you hook me
up with someone? Hey, can you, you know,
I'm helping me.
I'm trying to design a website.
I really don't know what I'm doing.
We don't really like to ask for help.
We tend to just sort of
take it all on ourselves.
But they've actually codified this
whole concept of asking and offering,
which is really amazing to me. So that
was one of the networks that I found. Um,
but again,
it's just sort of this whole sisterhood
that I feel like we're really feeling
across the country right now,
particularly even after the election.
As a side note,
I'm working on a project following
women who are running for office for the
first time and some of these candidates
have created their own political
networks of other women, which again,
completely sort of new and revolutionary,
which is really going to change the
whole landscape for women out there.
So to create, to create our serendipity,
we also have to have a strong network.
We need to be able to lean into to women.
We also need to be able to grow our
networks because of course there's all of
these studies that show you
only know who you know, right?
So you're not going to really get jobs
or find other opportunities only by the
network of people you know, you need
to keep expanding your boundaries.
So I thought this was pretty
fascinating too. And today,
as you all know in the tech space,
it's, you know, art meets technology,
retail meets technology,
entertainment meets technology.
There's all these intersections today.
And the more that we push out and
meet people who we don't yet know and
experience industries that we
don't, who we don't, you know,
or aren't familiar with, the more
opportunity we have for ourselves. Um,
and then the last or a theme that I
was really sort of into because it's so
obvious is branding, right?
How do we talk about ourselves?
How do we sort of share who we are?
Again,
this is a concept that a lot of
women can be very squeamish about.
We don't like to brag about ourselves.
We don't like to boast
about what we've done.
And this really came to light when I was,
um,
I was speaking in Washington DC a
few weeks ago to a group of 50 female
attorneys,
all of them unemployed because they had
all either worked at the White House for
Obama or for the Justice
Department under Obama.
So we had 50 democratic women,
female attorneys,
all looking for a job.
And they said, you know,
it was in November when when
Hillary lost the election,
they knew they were going to need to
find a new job and they started writing
their resumes and they said,
we work with all of these men.
And you would have thought by looking
at these guys resumes that they were
running the justice department. They
basically everything big that happened,
they own, they did where the women
really thought, well, I was like, I mean,
I was at that meeting, I was on that team,
you know, I can't really say I did that,
you know, but the guys that, you know,
they were like running the west wing also.
So,
you know,
it's such interesting gender divide in
how we own what it is that we do and how
we share with the world
what it is that we do.
But the only way for people to know
is that visibility again, right?
Everything is online,
everything is through social media.
Everything is about networking.
If we don't tell people
what it is that we do well,
they're not going to know what we do well.
And so particularly when you're looking
for a job or you're looking to pivot or
you're looking to explore,
you're keeping your eyes open.
People need to know what it
is that you do well, you know,
as the kids call it today, like
what's your superpower? But you know,
surely you need to sort of own your own
narrative and what it is that you do and
be able to share that with the world
and not feel so squeamish about it.
You know, it has been sort of
thought to be impolite to brag,
but I would like to sort of change
that whole notion that, you know,
branding yourself is not
necessarily bragging.
It's about letting people know what
it is in the world that we do. Um,
so I would love to like open this up
to questions if anyone has questions so
he's more fun to take questions.
Question.
Yup.
You most experience being a working woman,
married and having kids,
some of your preferences now that
to life with the attorney. Um,
and I look back at,
I personally think I'm more,
I feel Golda and more confident and more
willing to take risk monitor everything
from not my job,
everything actually off to having a child.
So that was a positive even though
it presents it to him stream,
but it also look back at
my ESL and I'm like, wow,
what a squandered opportunity to do
more. Someone. That's a great point.
I guess some of the people in this room
don't have it yet. Have you found me?
I'm wondering what those of us to do
who doesn't yet have some of those other
times,
another commitment.
I think that's a great point.
And I would say use that free time
before you have children to your fullest.
Explore everything that you can, you
know, this is the time to create,
you know,
all of those,
seize those opportunities
and do everything that it
is that you want to do from
also even just traveling,
seeing the world and having experiences.
Because certainly in the early years
and Zebra is young, you know, it's hard.
It's hard.
My kids are teenagers now and it's
easier to have that also mental space.
So I would not have been able to
write this book a few years ago.
I think that we also need that headspace
to be able to explore and to noodle and
to get creative.
Um,
I also think that it's really important
for all of us at any stage in your life
to really get comfortable in
the uncomfortable. You know,
that's the navy seals expression,
um, for obvious reasons. Uh,
and I'm sure it's been adopted by others,
but I really, I really by that belief,
because that gives us all that opportunity
to get used to feeling a little
uncomfortable. That's where
the greatest, you know,
that's where all the amazing things
that we're going to do are going to come
from.
That's where we're going,
able to be able to grow the most and
taking jobs that make us nervous,
right? Like when we get too complacent,
we're not bringing our a game. Um,
and I'll see, you know, what's risky for
one person is not risky for someone else.
So it's figuring out what
that risk is for you.
Anyone else?
Can you speak a bit more to the concept
of pivoting and we launching? So,
um,
how in in your career have you,
faced the need to pivot from perhaps
one particular field to a completely
different one? Or could you just talk a
bit more about how that plays out? Sure.
You know, um, I, I have,
I would say that the through line
to my career has been storytelling,
but that's before it was even
called storytelling, right?
It was called, you know,
reporting. It was called journalism.
It's called writing. Now.
It's all storytelling. Um, I did,
I really wanted to move into,
I wanted to get some tech experience,
although I'm not an engineer,
I'm so not that kind of experience.
I've never coded before,
but I wanted to work for a tech company.
So I had started on the hill.
So I started in politics and then I
moved to New York and I worked in TV.
I worked at dateline,
NBC and Fox.
And then Larry Ellison was starting this
new Internet computer company and I got
a job to be his media director.
The company really blew up,
but it was my first experience going
to ces back in the day before cs became
like so wild. Um, and so I did that.
And then I actually written another book
I'm about on work life balance called
how she really does it.
And that actually led me into going into
what we would call the dark side for
journalists. But I went into PR and I
was doing the other side of it all, um,
which I actually had an okay
time with. Now, of course,
that's called branded content.
Everything that I was doing, you know,
say the vernacular, it keeps changing.
Um, so I would say that, you know,
there's a bunch of different things to,
to mention with pivoting for people
who are going and doing a full one 80,
you know,
like I want to become a dentist now,
we'll obviously that would be incredibly
different and would require me to go to
dental school. Um, but a lot of things
when people say that they're pivoting,
at least what I found,
there are things that are a little bit
almost companions to things that they're
doing so they're not completely
removed from their skillsets.
So my whole advice is about really
leaning into your skills and just figuring
out the new ones that you have to learn.
And as you know better than anyone,
you can do the stuff online.
There's a lot of ways to take classes
and you to have that whole side Gig that
everyone, you know, seems to feel
very romantic about these days.
But having that sort of side project
that you start noodling with to see,
you know,
is there a viability here?
Am I any good at it at can I make money
if I need to make money? You know,
what can I really do?
And what I've also found is just changing
the language of how we talk about
ourselves.
I will tell you,
I have scrubbed my linkedin profile
in the past 10 years probably,
you know,
35 times because I keep seeing where,
how job descriptions are being posted.
Now.
The language being used is so different
than the language I was using.
You know it.
So now everything that I've done in
my past seems to be storytelling and
marketing. I would never have called
myself a marketing person before.
But yet that's what branded content is
and that's what you know. And so it's,
the world just keeps changing.
So it's about also not feeling
like a fraud for calling yourself,
you know,
putting that label on when you feel like
that label isn't exactly what you went
to school for. But that's
what they're calling it now.
And yes, your skills apply.
So,
I'm not saying lie and be a fraud at all,
but I'm saying that we have to be a little
bit more open minded and realize that
to stay relevant you need to really see
where trends are going and see how you
fit in there. Or if you want,
I could do a total relaunch,
figure out what do you need to know
and learn to completely shift gears,
which could be incredibly different
than what you know right now.
Okay.
Hey there. I'm, so, I was actually
at the confidence girl code,
whatever it's called, a
conference. Yeah. Um, that, uh,
they hosted a catty, catty
Shipman and whatnot. And, and, uh,
Baltimore a few months ago
I was a panelist on the
stem panel and so I took my
daughter and we attended the whole
conference actually, and you know,
kind of a summary of some of the
messages I heard was, you know,
obviously be confidence, stand up
straight, you know, give a firm handshake,
look them in the eye, um, but
be authentic, be yourself.
And it was like this tug of war of,
um,
advice that I felt like was
kind of contradictory in
the message because at the
end of the day we're telling women to
sort of reshape themselves to be more
acceptable in the male
environment. Right. And, um,
one of the things that I really
liked about, you know, uh,
Google and like the Silicon Valley is
that this concept of you don't have to
wear a suit to be taken seriously.
And so, uh, the point is that you can,
you don't have to look a certain way as
a man or a sound a certain way or even
be particularly social,
socially acceptable to be taken seriously.
And you know,
what really mattered was
like that you were smart,
you had great ideas and you got the
thing done, right. So, I guess my,
this is probably more of a comment to
see you, what your response might be,
but my hope is that we can get to a
place where we can stop telling women to
change themselves and get to a place
where just like the culture we have built
here, you can be whatever you need
to be as a person and it's still,
you'll still be accepted because of the
you produce is excellent. Um, so you know,
that that's sort of, I guess I'm kind
of tired of hearing all the, you know,
do this, do that. And I did all those
things. And so when I sit on panels now,
would I say to the, to the young women
thinking about careers in tech is,
you know, I'm going to be honest
with you. You can give, you know,
you can stand up as straight
as you can stand up,
you can give from handshakes until
you make their knuckles bleed.
You can, you know, be the
smartest person in the room,
but you're always going to
be disadvantaged because
you're a woman and there's
literally nothing you can do
to change that. And so, uh,
you know,
I think you're making all very important
points that I think we can all really
appreciate. And you know,
one of the things that I,
when I was talking about it,
even writing about Hillary Clinton in
the book and the way she was perceived in
her shrill tone and she's not warm, she's
not authentic, she's too smiley. She's,
you know, whatever it may be. No one
likes the way she looks in her suits.
She needs to lose weight, all of that
kind of stuff. You're absolutely right.
And one of the women
who I quote in the book,
she talks about the fact that we
need to rehear the way women speak.
She actually makes this comparison to
pre title nine and sports and women that
the way that women in sports were
perceived, you know, 20 years ago,
I would argue still a bit today, um,
that they're not given the same validity.
They're certainly not
given the same money.
We see that with the u s soccer
team with a women's soccer, um,
that they make less than men, yet they
win way more than the guys do. Um,
but even that whole idea
that anyone should tune in
and watch women play soccer,
that has changed.
Right?
I would say that people still aren't
really watching the women and be a league
the way that they watched the men because
people say it's not as exciting. Um,
and they don't have the same
kind of money. But the idea,
the notion is that we as a country,
as a people need to rehear
the way that women speak.
So if a woman is sounding a little,
her voice is going to be higher than
most men because that's the way women are
built. To not discredit that
and not think that that is,
you know,
Q harsh or too bitchy or too annoying
that we almost adapt to that.
So I do think that, and maybe I'm
being a little Pollyanna here,
but I think as more women move up
the ranks and as we lift more women,
as the sisterhood keeps bringing women
up with, with them, and as I'm seeing,
and as I feel very strongly about
that things will start changing.
We'll see more females in technology.
We'll see more women
in leadership position,
we'll see more women in Congress and we
will adapt and accept the way they look,
the way they sound, they will,
the way that they communicate.
And that is when things
will start changing.
But even women don't like the
way that women present. I mean,
we really saw that play
out on the election.
It was really sort of shocking to so
many of us when we looked at the numbers
and we looked at, you
know, what was coming back.
It was like women just
didn't even like women.
And that's another big issue
of what needs to change.
Yeah. Yeah. I think I, you know,
I think what I'd like to see
is more books around how to,
how to be a person that can just
accept women the way they are. I mean,
I w the advice when I,
you know,
I heard the advice around don't
say I'm sorry you so much.
I've heard it a lot and I really tried
myself to not do it until I reached a
point where I was like, you
know what? Maybe we have it
right to say you're sorry.
It's like a good thing. It's like you're
being kind and empathetic, compassionate,
considerate.
Maybe the advice should be to the assholes
who treat people who say, I'm sorry,
badly to not do that. Right. As
opposed to the other way around.
Well, I think you're, you
know, being authentic.
There's nothing wrong with
being authentic. I think
that when we are authentic,
that is actually the people who come
across the most authentic are the ones who
get jobs are well liked and there's
tons of studies on all of that.
But when we are faking it,
people you know can size
that up in a millisecond.
I mean we see facial expressions and
we're sort of brilliant at seeing an
authenticity.
So keep being you.
In your research,
did you hear any murmurings or
indications that perhaps men,
are you learning and listening from
how you approach things? You know,
getting to the point
of closing one lately,
I don't think it's just what
can we learn from them, right?
And be better at what are we doing right.
Is there anything,
well,
I mean there are a lot of studies that
show that the nurturing skills that women
have are incredibly
effective in leadership.
And we also know that when women are at
the top and organizations when they have
more management roles, when they are
in c suite roles, businesses do better.
I mean that is like study after study
after study proves that diversity is good
for the bottom line. Um, I,
I didn't really see that the guys are
looking to women to sort of soften up or
to be more collaborative or to do
the things that women do so well,
I think that, you know, to, to the
other, I don't know your name, but
cat to caddies point,
that embracing who we are as women is
really important and really essential.
And, and I agree. We
don't need to change. Um,
we need to be aware of how we present
because the truth is the rest of the world
hasn't caught up to our shed. Um, so
we, I think it starts with an awareness,
even back to Tammy Reese's Gmail Plugin.
She's not saying,
never say just her actually or I'm sorry.
It's more of like an awareness
of how we're communicating. Um,
but I do think that women should be
leaning into all of this skills that we do
so well, which is we're
great collaborators. Right?
So even going back to that
whole idea about networking,
I've spoken to many rooms and
I'll say to women, you know,
who likes to network here? I mean, I
can ask you all who likes to network?
Anyone like to network? No. So,
okay, well you liked it. Well,
you're really confident,
authentic and good for you.
But so many women don't like to
now work. We feel that. It's like,
it makes us feel a little
like uncomfortable. You know,
we're like asking for something and
transactional and it feels very cold.
Um, guides it had been
doing it forever. Right?
They go in and they say what they need,
they're at, they get to be here, you know,
they go play golf, done. Women don't
like to do that, but we'll we're really,
really good at is building relationships
and we're really good at creating
relationships that last a long time.
We need to play the long game.
So I would argue that women,
we need to sort of rethink networking,
thinking of think of it more even like
relabeling that like we're connecting,
we're showing up and we are connecting
because women do that really, really well.
We bond very quickly. You put, you know,
if we were all sitting
together and like five minutes,
I'd know what you all did for a living,
where you lived.
If you were dating someone,
if you had a child,
I might comment and you're
like the coolest shoes that
you're wearing, you know,
whatever it may be.
That is what women bond very,
very naturally and very authentically.
So I really do think it's almost re
imagining what networking is and realizing
that we're building sort of relationships
with one another that are real,
that are authentic and that
we know will last awhile.
Folks.
I'm sorry if you have a question,
if you can use the two mikes just so
that the sound is picked up properly.
Thank you.
Um,
I think,
I mean obviously it's true that like I
think we have it right and I think we are
aware of that like of the issues that
women face that like woman women aren't
wrong for doing the things that they do
and the way they present being warm is
never a bad thing.
Being kind is never a bad thing.
But I mean I feel like we are in the very
vast minority of people who are aware
of this issue. And obviously you
mentioned um, Hillary Clinton,
like the, the vast majority
of America is not aware that,
you know, the things like not aware
of the biases that we are aware of.
So I guess like navigating
through this world. Like,
I obviously am not condoning that
we should like change or anything.
But you did mention like you wanted to
say sorry because you felt like that was
how you came off as warm.
So a warmer when,
cause I grew up people calling me bossy
all the time because I was confident and
I was able to say what I wanted without,
I'm not being rude but in just a
sense being direct. But how do you,
how do you avoid that?
Like what kinds of strategies?
Like could you delve more into like
other things you've tried as well?
Yeah, yeah, I do think that a
lot of it, his facial expression.
So the problem when I was
told that I was Abrasive,
I was actually working remotely.
So a lot of my conversations
were over the phone.
So I thought I was being very direct.
And My boss actually said to me,
who is a woman? She said, I know that
you're warm, I use smile. You know,
you're very engaging in person, but you
know, on the phone people think, you know,
you're a little bossy.
And again,
like a man would never have been accused
of being bossy. I was just direct.
I thought, um, you know, we've got time,
we've got 30 minutes on the call in out
done good. They're not seeing me smile,
you know, because it's on the phone.
Um, but I do think so that personal,
so what I have learned is I
do try to smile a lot. I mean,
it's not a natural for me to smile.
I'm,
I'm thinking I'm probably
now more aware of that.
And I also think maybe there's also comes
with a little bit more confidence and
age also of just, I'm not feeling
like I have something to prove,
so maybe I'm not coming
in, sit like, you know,
like the bull in the
China store type of thing,
that I'm a little bit
softer as I even speak. Um,
but yeah, I do. I am, I'm
hyper aware of how I present.
And so my advice to you
is smile, smile, warmth,
and then say what you need to say.
Be Smart.
Never Hedge on being smart as none of
us would do, I'm sure. But you know,
you want to come across
and make your points clear.
There was something else that,
um,
that I didn't mention when I was
talking that I think is actually really
interesting and it goes to sort of the
solidarity of the sisterhood in this
networking and the change that I'm seeing
and I write about and it's called the
amplification effect, if you all
heard of this. Yeah. Right. Right on.
So for those who don't know,
I had read about this and the Washington
Post that the women in the Obama White
House realized very early in the
administration that they were being,
they were being ignored,
they were ignored by the president and
by pretty much everyone in the west wing.
And they'd come into
meetings and you know,
the president never called on them for,
for questions or further thoughts
or anything like that. Um,
or if they did speak up,
their ideas were being usurped
by the guy in the room, you know,
so they made a point in all of a sudden,
you know, like John Zoning that point.
So they got together and they realized
that they needed to do something about
this and that they were going to
amplify each other's messages.
So if yes, if something brilliant
in a meeting with the president,
as I'm sure she has, um, I
would then say, you know,
as you said earlier and letting you know
now the point is being owned by Yaz.
I'm emphasizing that the president's
looking over it. Yasmina like, oh yeah,
smart lady. Um, good point.
And they started doing that.
They started making sure that they were
calling on each other and reinforcing
the comments to make sure that the guys
weren't stealing any of these ideas.
But something interesting happened,
which was that President Obama
started calling on the women more,
started inviting them to more meetings.
They were visible,
they made themselves visible.
So this whole concept of amplifying
each other is really important.
And certainly not just in the west
wing, but in the workspace, right?
We need to be supporting each other. We
need to be recognizing what we're saying,
what our contributions are.
And it's really,
really helpful to have
someone else do that for. Um,
I don't know if anyone here read
Jessica had bandits book. Um,
and I'm going to screw up the name.
It's the feminist fight club is her,
is her book and which is a great read.
And she writes about having a boast bitch
and that boosts bitch is someone who,
by the way he, it could be your best
friend, it could be your mother,
it could be your sister,
it's having someone be able
to amplify messages for you.
And I'm sure there's tons of studies on
with Facebook likes and Instagram likes
and you know what gets the most likes
and all this kinds of stuff. But there,
but there is something to be said when
someone else says something about you or
someone posts something like, oh I'm
so proud of, you know, my wife for her,
you know, her book was published
that tends to get more likes.
And if I actually put out, Hey,
my book was published, you know,
so it's the same sort of concept.
So you have someone else.
You have someone who amplifying the
great work that you're doing in the
workplace, and having that boast bitch
is really effective. And I, first of all,
I just loved the idea.
Um,
and I think it's very empowering and very
much of the sisterhood that we need to
be supporting each other.
I know I digressed.
Does anyone have any other questions?
I think we need to wrap it up. Okay.
Thank you all. Thank you guys for inviting
me. Thank you Google for having me.
This is quite an honor to be here.
Truly.
I'm thrilled to have been able to speak
at Google. This is really very exciting.
Thank you.